[Musique]
macarthur devaient tenir en gaspésie à
grande-vallée là vous avez un quatrième
album pour voir et vous dites que c'est
votre album de la crise de la
quarantaine
je dirais que c'est un album de
questionnements qui vient probablement
je me suis après autour analyser ça
vient probablement de de toutes les
questions qui tournent autour du
changement mais ça vient avec leurs
questionnements leur positionnement dans
beaucoup de choses comment se positionne
comme artiste comme mère artiste comme
après avoir fait trois albums comment je
le revois avec un super frais pour
triper pour pour vibrer vraiment encore
dans vie pour faire les choses de la
même façon
une de mes chansons préférées c'est
votre nouvel album c'est chez moi mon
coeur je reçois que vous avez écrites
pour votre fils
quel message avez vous voulu passé
révolu et à moi même je pense s'il me
passer un message de
c'est comme quand un enfant fonctionne -
comme à l'école comme les autres cellier
tdh il ya plein de petites choses qui
fonctionnent pas nécessairement dans le
cadre normal puis satire du jus à un
enfant de 2 toujours en train de vouloir
rentrer dans le même moule alors que si
on mettait juste l'importance le focus
sur les aptitudes il serait plein plein
de vie et plein plein d'espoir tout le
temps mais dans un contexte comme ça
c'est comme ça c'est certain de la
misère ça ça n'a cessé mais la fois que
sur ce qui est pas facile pour quelqu'un
à tous les jours puis pour réparer si
c'est dur de de lui demander de regarder
tout le temps dans cette direction là on
le dirait je souhaitais vendanges à 6
trip de même mais on prendra pas le
temps de tout parce qu'on est dans un
dans ce contexte là mais je trouve ça je
trouve ça super dur de d'offrir soit
quelqu'un d'avoir juste ça après j'avais
juste envie de mettre de prendre cinq
minutes puis de regarder de l'autre côté
dire ça c'est ce qu'on va faire
puis moi aussi ça me fait du bien
d'imaginer de me détendre dans cette
situation vous fait vraiment partie de
la gagne car croit en oblique ariane
moffatt doit vous partagez votre vie
avec un membres de karkwa françois
lafontaine
comment ça se passe à la maison ce que
vous parlait tout le temps musique
qu'est-ce que toujours en train de
travailler sur la prochaine chance non
pas du tout maintenant moi je suis pas
compartimenté si la musique débarque un
mauvais moment dans l'histoire ça tombe
bien car j'ai vraiment besoin de sentir
que même et françois lui est toujours
plus d'un
dans le match dans sa tête dans une
poule mais moi je vraiment je fonctionne
caché dans avec mon fils ma maison je
suis pas dans la musique
pantoute gcc très compartimentée que
j'ai besoin de ça aussi pour être pour
être les cas ça commence parce que sinon
je peux pas tout prendre en même temps
c'est s'est éteint tout seul ce serait
trop intense si la musique était tout le
temps ici au même plan que la famille au
même plan que mes amis m'ont plaqué tout
le réseau d'amis je suis en plein
spectacle et vous avez une relation
particulière avec votre instrument la
base qu'est ce qu'ils signifient pour
vous cet instrument pour moi ces
supports physiques comme instrument ça
se ressent vraiment c'est comme chantait
que c'est aussi c'était aussi
sensorielle que chanter vos - je la
baisse célébration et son super ça c'est
presque charnelle jaune a b c comme
champ texte aux six organique
[Musique]
ça fait longtemps que j'avais pas fait
ce n est là pour partait en tournée ce
que ça vous en croise d'entreprendre
justement cet exercice qui parfois de
quoi être péri de mon gestionnaire mais
oui c'est aussi un angoissant que
l'ophone la raison pour laquelle cécile
phone c'est parce qu'on a traversé la
angoisse donc c'est comme un soulagement
à chaque fois je vois ma vie en tournée
conciliation famille tourner beaucoup
beaucoup de solutions à trouver de ce
côté là mais sinon ça fait longtemps que
j'ai pas fait et que je peux faire 2,5
puis j'avais très très très envie de le
faire fait que ça va je vois je vois en
profiter macarthur g
il
[Musique]